artificial intelligence is part of the
new frontier in medicine it's the topic
of this morning's this morning of our
series Grand Rounds which is the
practice of medicine practice of medical
professionals who teach other doctors
about advancements in a new study we
told you about earlier this week
researchers at Google used an algorithm
to analyze eye scans as a method for
predicting heart disease artificial
intelligence is being used to quickly
analyze data to identify patterns that
can help speed up diagnosis and your
treatment the combination of high-tech
computing and hands-on medicine is
transforming medical care our dr. David
agus directs research on AI at the
University of Southern California he
also heads USC's westside Cancer Center
he's a very busy dude but he joins us at
the table this morning good morning to
you dr. Dave good morning I'm still
scared about the payback threat to watch
what I say but this is the thing I think
will you use a technical term in the
green room it's so freakin cool to quote
that's what he said about AI what
excites you most so AI is getting
computers to do think that humans did
before and so they could take over our
tasks and so they're Google this week
showed that if you look at the back of
the eye it's called the fundus there are
blood vessels there and they took 280
thousand of those scans and now they can
actually look in the back of one's eye
tell you your sex your age plus or minus
three years they could tell you where
you're smoked your blood pressure and
most importantly your risk for heart
disease just by looking inside you're
all done by computer all done by
computer because they look for patterns
that the human brain couldn't have seen
but they saw I mean imaging is one of
the fields where AI can really do
wonders right it is doing wonders so
computers are better at picking up
tuberculosis than humans are you know
imagine you're in a number of emergency
room and there's a hundred x-rays a
doctor has to look at well maybe the
computer can look first and say hey doc
pay attention to this one because we
think it may be pneumonia and that
patient could be treated quicker because
they go to the head of the line their
x-ray so there's a lot of potential how
it's gonna transform what we do as
physicians when you get excited about
this we've gotten excited about a lot of
technological developments and then two
months later we're doing stories about
everybody's freaked out about them so
when you think about this excitement do
you think about it in the context of the
doctor's office or
you think about it in context of I'm at
home staring into a retinal scanner and
doing an at-home test it's a great
question you know I mean AI is a lot of
things AI is as simple as computers
calling you to confirm your appointment
you know I think there's certain tests
that doctors just aren't as good at so
if you're looking under a microscope at
breast cancer and there's one cancer
cell you have to look at a thousand
cells a normal cancer normal cancer the
human brain is not that good at that the
computer could do it all at once so
there are certain things it's gonna take
over and do really well other things
will be in the purview of the physician
there still will be and always will be
an art to medicine the cool thing about
AI it's gonna make the good doctors
great and so that's what's exciting to a
re and heart disease yes we've been
teasing that all morning how does that
work well in the Google example it can
look at the back of the eye and from
those blood vessels it can predict heart
disease in England they used AI to look
at patient's medical records and they
were better at predicting who's gonna
get heart disease than the current
algorithms of the American Heart
Association so all of a sudden it's
going to be added on to what we do as a
doctor we're gonna get these clues the
computer gonna say hey you should
consider this because even though they
don't meet the standard criteria we
think they might why is there so much
information in the eye David because
it's known that yeah yeah back in the
eye you could see blood vessel yeah and
you could see whether they're a little
bit thicker in certain areas or not and
you can actually as an indicator of the
blood vessels all over the body so it's
an element that gives us clues yeah your
eye doctor when they're looking to give
you my glasses version should be looking
and could could spot some other health
concerns concerns as well I have a
question about about AI and privacy
because certainly we could at one point
reached the point where genetic
information gets the data all gets
loaded up into some cloud and that
becomes both helpful and troublesome no
question about it so George Bush passed
the genetic non-discrimination Act Gina
about a decade ago so it protects us
from this but you're right there's the
potential for overuse for potential
using it for other things and we have to
be very careful about security and about
taking away identifiers when we start to
mine or look at this information so it's
something that needs governance we need
to have somebody in charge make sure we
use AI correctly to make sure we protect
privacy and that we do it right in the
long run yeah
must've talked about the pitfalls of AI
for civilization same thing in medicine
oh no question about it I mean AI use it
appropriately it to make decisions that
aren't under our control use in the
right way we're actually gonna make
things better hopeful yeah thank you
thank you dr. David IGAs good to have
you at the table